so uh bar huh Jimmy part um so we had so
it was this is sorry so you know my
Korean boyfriend him and Bart were best
friends how dare you I didn't break him
up but um yeah we were part of the same
friend circle yeah and then and then
they like we were kind of like we broke
up and then we just remained friends and
then we just are you guys still friends
with that guy no oh good you leave him
in a day he's disgraced the current and
then so how did the whole Jake a new
start uh Jay King ok so it started off
with JK films that was born Jo and then
yeah they they went on like a hiatus
because they're like we got to pursue
school like we got like everyone was
about the degree at that time yeah and
then they were like you know like the
degree things not working like I I think
they read like a Forbes article where
they had like nigahiga who was like
number one at that time he was making
like six seven figures no I'm like we're
doing the wrong thing um so like alright
we're gonna hit this thing full force
and then at that time Bart now we're
together and then they were like hey you
majored in business right I'm like yeah
I kind of got my degree in that they're
like can you just like help us with a
couple things here and there and then um
I came full time in that thing and then
that kind of blew up a little bit more
and then like we always had like you
guys know like the Asian Circle like you
go to a restaurant you guys are like
talking whatever then you go to the
parking lot and then there's like
another circle developers yeah yeah and
you're talking for another two hours
so then Bart was never happened to me
I've never been approached agents or
renegade really no but I've never I want
no no I'm not I want to go to an Asian
Circle and then just dispersed and then
go to another one you saying that you
had a bunch of Asian people who want you
to come out there's more Asians out in
the parking lot I mean it's like this
circle right and then we're done yeah
and we go and like that's what I'm
saying I want to go to others break it
out yeah yeah but I haven't done that
anyway yeah you guys got all weird about
it it's no I feel like you are the
circle you create the circle
there are a lot of Asians in your high
school yeah Matt you ADA one person yeah
are there a lot and at you eight I grew
up with mostly whites one black guy San
Diego in Poway a bunch of white people
and um yeah I mean we just had a lot of
just uh but I you know I hung onto the
hashers the pot smokers yeah Zappa you
know those guys you know and so that's
why I became Who I am you're awesome
no I wanted I want I wanted not awesome
yeah you I wonder what you have well
what do I have I wanted to be a part of
a group I want what is this this is
awesome this jealous this is this is
Cesar yes okay yeah it's different yeah
this is Cesar this is the Roman Empire
and I run the [ __ ] plan I'm just a
sergeant the dead people at the
gladiators no no no you're the guy at
the stable and we have these chariots
and these horse and I clean no you just
kind of [ __ ] with your [ __ ] mouth
okay great your mouth we don't give a
sháá yeah what a voice you're popular
dude this one right here what is he dead
in it each day is a dead person
what about dr. [ __ ] oh [ __ ] man he's
my um court jester oh he comes in with
this [ __ ] well but just in
hypothetically he would come in with his
little tighty-whiteys yeah and he'd have
whips marks on his body because he's
been bad oh he's been bad
and then his eyes right it's shiny right
underneath his eyes do you know why well
there's a volunteers that drive
oh just layers of tears have dried
underneath her eyes eyes oh it's a haze
I'm sorry bloodshot red because I don't
feed it and I it's it rice down a he he
bleeds internally yeah but I stance and
he comes any weapon he feeds wipes yeah
and this is my queen
oh good the clean horses but at night
she goes don't do that too right after
unfuckable doctor I go yeah anyway I was
go on so you had Asian circles in the
party yeah and that was yeah that's it
that's how that was the birth of JK news
yes why the [ __ ] yeah I was so organic
it was just chill whoa yeah I mean God
I'll bet can I be honest with you always
I I've always been kind of jealous of
you guys you guys did it you guys did it
right what did we do there's just some
sort of a cultish following that you
have that's beyond fans they're like
family but it reaches so many people and
when I should try to dive into that
market or that platform which is the
Internet
I couldn't get anything going
[Music]